[Música]
tras salir victorioso de una moción de
censura dentro del partido conservador
el primer ministro británico gordon song
aseguró que el resultado es
extremadamente bueno así se concluye un
nuevo capítulo del escándalo por las
fiestas ilegales en downing street
durante la pandemia
una multitudinaria caravana de
emigrantes salió desde el sur de méxico
rumbo a eeuu justamente el tema
migratorio es un punto clave de la
agenda en la novena cumbre de las
américas que comenzó en los ã ngeles un
encuentro marcado por varias ausencias
el ministro del medioambiente de
república dominicana orlando jorge mera
murió asesinado a manos de un amigo de
infancia que le disparó varias veces en
su oficina el autor confesó el crimen
tras ser capturado por las autoridades
en france 24 estamos de vuelta con las
noticias que marcan las jornadas hoy
valentina torres anchas y es un gusto
acompañarlos comenzamos en reino unido
el primer ministro británico boris
johnson calificó como una victoria el
haber superado una moción de censura
dentro del partido conservador el
funcionario logró el apoyo del 59% de
los diputados de su partido y reiteró
que planea seguir al frente del gobierno
asimismo despejó dudas sobre la
posibilidad de convocar elecciones
anticipadas estas fueron sus palabras
creo que este es un resultado muy bueno
para la política y para el país en este
sentido creo que es un resultado
contundente un resultado decisivo y lo
que significa es que como gobierno
podemos seguir adelante y enfocarnos en
las cosas que creo que realmente le
importan a la gente de fútbol porque
somos todos tívoli marsans
pero como llegó a boris johnson a esta
moción de censura repasamos los
episodios que llevaron al primer
ministro británico a esta situación en
informes de manuel acá no
un voto de confianza y muchos escándalos
comenzaron en mayo de 2020 cuando un
reino unido estaban prohibidas las
reuniones de más de dos personas el 15
de ese mes el primer ministro y su
esposa tuvieron una reunión de trabajo
con vino y aperitivos junto a varios de
sus empleados el lugar su residencia
oficial de downing street el cumpleaños
56 de johnson fue motivo de una fiesta
sorpresa presuntamente organizada por su
esposa con una treintena de asistentes
después al final del año mientras en el
país había cerca de 400 muertes diarias
por kobe 19 en downing street se
multiplicaban las celebraciones
prohibidas para los británicos
el 16 de abril de 2021 tuvo lugar uno de
los hechos más polémicos un festejo con
alcohol en la víspera del funeral del
esposo de la reina isabel segunda el
príncipe felipe en diciembre cuando
estas celebraciones prohibidas empezaron
a conocerse el primer ministro negó toda
responsabilidad
desde que salieron a la luz estas
denuncias me han asegurado en varias
ocasiones que no hubo fiesta y que no se
cumplieron las restricciones anti kobe
volver al colocar también ese mes su
grey vicesecretaria de la oficina del
gabinete toma el mando de la
investigación sobre los hechos y el 25
de enero de 2022 la policía británica
hace lo propio días después un informe
preliminar de craig revela que se
infringieron algunas de las medidas de
la pandemia y muestra fallas en el
liderazgo de johnson el 12 de abril el
primer ministro su esposa y el ministro
de economía son multados por la policía
pero johnson se niega a dimitir y
reitera sus disculpas ante el parlamento
pekín pero jiménez y permítanme comenzar
con toda humildad diciendo que el 12 de
abril recibe una sanción relacionada con
un evento en downing street el 19 de
junio de 2020
de inmediato
y
en total 83 personas fueron multadas por
la policía y ahora en el más reciente
capítulo del escándalo del partit y
boris johnson su principal protagonista
sobrevive a la moción de censura de su
propio partido
la ciudad de los ángeles en california
eeuu es el escenario de la novena cumbre
de las américas el anfitrión el
presidente yo vaivén espera estrechar
los lazos con el resto del continente
sin embargo la casa blanca no invitó a
representantes de los gobiernos de cuba
nicaragua y venezuela esto llevó al
presidente mexicano andrés manuel lópez
obrador a no asistir no obstante envió a
su canciller a marcelo ebrard el
mandatario uruguayo luis lacalle pou
tampoco estará presente tras ser
diagnosticado con kobe 19
nosotros valoramos las opiniones
el señor presidente de lópez obrador
sin embargo el tema de las constantes
violaciones a los derechos humanos en
cuba en particular pero también en
nicaragua y venezuela es algo que
preocupa al señor presidente entonces
para la tradición del tema de respetar
los derechos humanos algo importantísimo
para
para nuestro país y para nuestro
presidente una nueva caravana de miles
de migrantes partidos del sur de méxico
rumbo a eeuu
ellos esperan hacer coordinar su llegada
con la cumbre de las américas entretanto
la organización human rights watch
publicó un informe en el cual denuncia
abusos sistemáticos contra migrantes por
parte de autoridades de eeuu y méxico en
su frontera común
es una de las caravanas de inmigrantes
más grandes de los últimos años más de
6000 personas mayoritariamente de
venezuela huyen de la violencia y de las
condiciones precarias la caravana salió
de tapachula en el sur de méxico donde
los migrantes han estado esperando sin
conseguir visas humanitarias y vas a
eeuu
hermano tenemos ya casi un mes aquí y no
lo han solucionado lo de la visa
humanitaria
queremos un futuro para nuestra familia
no somos violentos coordinaron su
recorrido con el inicio de la cumbre de
las américas que empezó este lunes en
los ángeles y se espera que aborde el
tema de la migración
el presidente de lópez obrador decidió
creo
cumbre de las américas nosotros le
pedimos como seres humanos de la
hispanoamérica que se pongan de acuerdo
son demasiadas personas migrantes
saliendo de lo que han querido convertir
a tapachula en una gran cárcel
migratoria este lunes la organización
human rights watch publicó un informe
denunciando abusos sistemáticos por
parte de eeuu y méxico contra los
migrantes la externalización de control
migratorio de eeuu a méxico ha dado
lugar a graves abusos y ha obligado a
cientos de miles de personas a esperar
en condiciones espantosas para buscar
protección a la ong denuncia la política
del presidente joe biden que ha
presionado a méxico para aumentar las
restricciones para ingresar y viajar
dentro del país haciendo aún más difícil
para los solicitantes de asilo de
obtener protección y haciendo de su
viaje hacia eeuu una travesía más
peligrosa human rights watch pidió a los
jefes de estado del continente
comprometerse para asegurar protección
para los migrantes
el ministro de medioambiente y recursos
naturales de república dominicana
orlando jorge mera fue asesinado a tiros
en su oficina así lo dio a conocer el
gobierno del presidente luís abinader de
acuerdo con el reporte el ministro una
mera murió a manos de miguel cruz un
amigo cercano de infancia pues fue
capturado por la policía dominicana y ha
sido indagado serán indagados sus
motivos para cometer el asesinato
tres testimonios de empleados del
ministerio del medio ambiente indicaron
que escucharon al menos siete disparos
en el interior de la oficina del
ministro era de 55 años era abogado de
profesión e hijo del ex presidente
dominicano salvador jorge blanco quien
gobernó república dominicana entre 1982
y
1986 las informaciones que manejamos
hasta ahora indican que en horas de la
mañana de hoy el ministro de
medioambiente perdió la vida al ser
atacado en su despacho con un arma de
fuego miguel cruz la persona
identificada como la que disparó era un
amigo personal del fallecido
el responsable se encuentra bajo
custodia de la policía nacional y el
ministerio público los motivos del hecho
se encuentran bajo investigación y vamos
a colombia un juez de la ciudad de
cartagena envió a prisión a las cinco
personas detenidas por presuntamente
estar involucradas en el asesinato del
fiscal paraguayo marcelo pecci a puerta
cerrada se llevó a cabo la audiencia de
imputación de cargos y medida de
aseguramiento con ambas decisiones se
busca garantizar la seguridad de los
testigos y de los funcionarios
involucrados en la investigación
teniendo en cuenta que días atrás los
detenidos amenazaron al juez durante la
audiencia de legalización de su captura
cuatro de los cinco detenidos por el
asesinato de peche aceptaron los cargos
de homicidio agravado y porte ilegal de
armas
terminamos en brasil donde autoridades
indígenas denunciaron que el periodista
británico don philips colaborador del
diario the guardian y el indigenista
brasileño bruno araújo pereira
desaparecieron el domingo en el valle de
javarí una de las regiones más remotas
de la amazonía en un comunicado
informaron que araujo un profundo
conocedor de la zona había recibido
amenazas desde hace unos días por parte
de invasores
así llegamos al final de esta emisión
les agradecemos su sintonía volvemos en
breve aquí en france24
[Música]